وفي ردود الفعل من كييف تحدثت القوات
الاوكرانيه عن تمكنها من اختراق تحصينات
روسيه في شرق البلاد والتقدم على جبهات
بخموت اما الرئيس الاوكراني
كانت له تصريحات عديده على مدار اليوم
تفاعل فيها مع الاحداث في روسيا زيلينسكي
قال ان تمرد عناصر مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
كشف عن فوضى كامله في روسيا واضاف ان
بلاده لن تسقط ولن تقف مكتوفه الايدي كما
انها قادره على حمايه اوروبا من الشر
والفوضى الروسيه بحسب تعبيره
اليوم هو يوم لا ينبغي ان يكون فيه صمت
بالتاكيد ونحن بالتاكيد بحاجه الى قياده
راى العالم اليوم ان ساده روسيا لا
يسيطرون على اي شيء لا شيء على الاطلاق
ببساطه فوضى كامله والافتقار الى اي
امكانيه للتنبؤ
تثير تطورات في روسيا اهتمام دول الجوار
حيث دعت جورجيا الى بحث وضع منطقه ابخزيه
واسيتيا الانفصاليتين وذكرت وزاره
الداخليه البيلاروسيه انها تتابع عن كثب
الاوضاع في روسيا وان قواتها تنفذ خدمتها
بالتوافق مع سير الاحداث من جانبه قال
مكتب الرئيس الكازاخستاني قاسم عند الرئيس
عقد اجتماعا لمناقشه المخاطر التي تواجه
بلاده بسبب الوضع في روسيا